we have to talk about the corona virus
outbreak that is taking place worldwide
and I know that all week I've been
getting emails from people saying David
when are you going to talk about this
and honestly what's had me not talk
about it so far is that I don't want to
be spreading fear and panic about
disease outbreaks and we were really
careful back during the highly
politicized Ebola situation during the
2014 midterms I lived in New York City
at the time and there was famously a
person who came back from I don't
remember where in West Africa went to
Brooklyn Bowl Brooklyn the Brooklyn Bowl
near where I lived in Brooklyn and
turned out that he had symptoms had
Ebola and the the term Ebola
started showing up on Twitter and a lot
of panic started to spread and as it
turned out a lot of that Ebola situation
was very political the day after the
2014 midterms
you didn't hear almost a word about the
Ebola so-called outbreak so I want to be
careful about not spreading irrational
fear and panic so to begin with the
corona virus outbreak is an outbreak it
is not a pandemic that is not the right
word to assign to it right now
coronavirus this particular corona virus
is known as 20:19 and CoV it is
considered a respiratory illness
initially it seems as though the source
is Wuhan China and specifically it
seemed like it was a seafood and meat
market in Wuhan which suggested animal
to person spread that has started to
change because there are more and more
patients that have had no exposure to
animal markets suggesting person the
person transmission could be both right
now it's just not completely clear based
on what the CDC has put out in general
corona viruses are coming from animals
they can come from camels cattle cats
bats and some other animals when it
spreads between people it is often via
respiratory droplets meaning you cough
or you sneeze and there are micro
droplets someone else breeze them in or
it gets into their
membranes in other ways it's still
unclear again a lot of this is still
under development under investigation
symptoms are typically fever cough and
shortness of breath the symptoms
sometimes don't appear for 14 days after
exposure which makes this very tricky
but it does mean if you've been in China
within the last two weeks or around
people who came back from China during
that time and you have symptoms you
should immediately call your doctor
there have been deaths from this there
have been deaths from this and we'll get
to those numbers in a second again the
outbreak centered around Wuhan China we
actually have a few viewers in that
region cases have been spreading in
terms of countries you have China of
course affected as well as Hong Kong
Macau Taiwan Australia Cambodia Canada
France Germany Japan Malaysia Nepal Sri
Lanka Singapore Thailand South Korea the
UAE the US and Vietnam I read this
morning in an Argentinean newspaper that
there are a couple of cases under
observation in Peru as of right now it's
unclear whether that is or is not this
strain of coronavirus it has reached the
United States as of this morning there
are cases confirmed in Washington state
California Arizona and Illinois five
patients testing positive in total by
the time you listen to or watch this
segment that number may have increased
no vaccine right now there are basic
prevention measures hand-washing for at
least 20 seconds coughing and sneezing
as I call it with respect I am shocked
almost daily about the number of adults
who seem to either not understand this
or not care walking around people just
coughing into the open air right on top
of me on public transit at the grocery
store how do we not know this at this
point okay
if you were sick stay home difficult
when a lot of people can't afford to
miss work I get it but if you're sick
stay home is the directive if you're
traveling by airplane you've got to be
an adult in terms of the symptoms now
the directive is if you feel feverish or
have a fever you've got to tell the
airline you've got to be taken off the
flight
now I know if you're at the end of a
long trip and it's time to get on the
plane and you're not feeling well most
people want to get home unless it is so
acute that you need to go to a hospital
right away
most people rationalize I'll be better
off at home than abroad if I'm sick I
don't want to be stuck here I want to
see my doctor I'll pretend I'm fine I'm
not gonna mention my fever I'm gonna get
on the plane I get it okay but we've got
to do the right thing because this is
going to continue to spread if you're
having symptoms and you are going to
your doctor call ahead tell them it's
conceivable that you have this so that
they can take the right steps to make
sure you don't show up and get other
people sick wear one of those face masks
when you're with other people and that
you're at your doctor's office you may
be asked to wear one just do it if you
have pets and this is important because
there does appear to be animal human
contagion here you've got to try to
avoid touching your pets because this
can spread from humans to animals we
just don't know everything about it yet
and if you have to have contacts with
your pets as most of you do if you
understand the psychology of dogs it's
hard not to be near your dog you may
want to consider wearing one of the
masks around your pets as well so let's
work together to stop the spread right
now about 7700 cases worldwide all but
68 of those are in mainland China
the death toll currently 130 mostly
older folks as of right now so we're
going to be following it this is not
about panicking people but this is about
understanding the risks and the spread
and what's going on I know that the
David Pakman show audience is full of
curious and creative people who love
learning new things and bettering
themselves and that's why I'm so excited
to tell you about one of our sponsors
Skillshare the vibrant online learning
community that offers thousands of
classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class
about photography if anybody follows me
on Instagram you know that my
photography skills leave much to be
desired and it was great I got so much
out of it and hopefully you will see the
fruits of me taking that class reflected
in my Instagram pictures sooner than
later they have classes for every skill
level whether you're wanting to get
better at something you already have
experience with you want to learn
something totally new to you you set
your own pace classes are usually less
than an hour long they're divided up
into bite-size segments so you can
easily fit them into your schedule make
2020 a year where you explore new skills
deep in existing passions get lost in
creativity Skillshare really makes it
easier than ever Skillshare memberships
are less than 10 bucks a month and that
gives you access to the thousands of
classes they offer but everybody in the
David Pakman show audience gets a
Skillshare membership totally free for
two whole months just go to david
pakman.com slash skill that's david
pakman.com slash s ki ll